a Japanese fella
has has just spent fourteen thousand
dollars to make himself look like a
border collie he looks like Lassie
uh he spent it on a costume mercifully
this was not a a very extensive hair
plug surgery or any other cosmetic
surgery it's just it's a costume it's
very convincing costume
uh he he goes by the name Toco
and he just shared a video of him
stepping out in public for the first
time rolling around in the park in front
of children dressed up as a dog
uh he has 42 000 subscribers on YouTube
and this is not just a prank or
something which would be kind of funny
he he sincerely wants to be an animal
that's what he says on the channel and
and then
here's what else he says he says do you
remember your dreams from when you were
little
you want to be a hero or a wizard I
remember writing in my grade school
graduation book that I wanted to be a
dog and walk around outside
yeah yeah sure
first of all in his defense
his costume is much more persuasive than
so he's done better there than a lot of
confused people
but this is very sad
and
what's saddest about it is he seems to
be somewhat conscious of the of the
problem here you see that he says the
problem he says do you remember your
dreams from when you were little
well I'm just doing that as an adult
that's the problem and I think that's
what's underlying a lot of the
pathologies in our society not just
people having imaginary identities
but
the people who refuse to grow up
the people who they get married but they
don't they don't want to really get
married you know they want to keep their
lives mostly separate they don't want to
change their name they don't want to get
a shared bank account they don't want to
change any aspect of their lives it's
it's I guess it's technically a marriage
but it's not it's still people holding
on to their individualism
or they get married but they don't want
to have kids even if they can't have
kids they don't want to have kids they
don't want to or let's say they don't
want to get married marriage rates have
plummeted or they don't want to be in a
serious relationship or they don't want
to
buy a house or they don't want to
commit really to anything which is a
major problem for the millennial
generation we'll see how it affects the
older Zoomers
it's all back to this problem that the
Border Collie Man is identifying which
is
say well when I was a little kid
I
I didn't want to do those things when I
was a little kid I wanted to do X Y and
Z and so I'm just going to keep doing X
Y and Z for the rest of my life
it's very sad this ties in with the
Barbie movie actually it's one of the
things I really liked about the Barbie
movie I won't talk about the Barbie
movie too much but
the Barbie movie
plot begins
because Barbie is stuck in this
perpetual
pointless present
in Barbie land at the beginning of the
movie every day is exactly the same wake
up go to the beach haha they do Beach
you know they kind of walk around the
beach then there's a party at Barbie's
house and they all go to the party but
then the boys have to go away because
it's girls night and then they just and
they do the exact same thing every day
and the movies plot really begins when
Barbie says wait a second you guys ever
think about death
you ever think about time you ever think
about aging and changing and and that's
the the driving theme throughout the
movie
growing up and what it means not just
for an individual but even passing on
to the Next Generation and how a society
grows up and we've stopped that and it's
no wonder that as we've stopped the
process of individual maturation as
we've stopped uh looking at and admiring
older people and shifted our Focus as a
society to now we say we need to learn
from the children children know
everything we need to listen to them
about everything we need to trust
everything that they say we have to
assume that they have perfect faculties
of Reason well Grandma she doesn't know
what she's talking about throw her in a
home kill her through euthanasia old
people don't old people are dumb and
stupid and racist probably and they
don't matter and they should just die
but young little children they know
everything that's that bizarre inversion
of society
has led to a society that is dying
because it won't grow up
like this guy will grow up it's not it's
not bad that when he was five years old
he said I want to be a doggy that's kind
of cute it's childlike
but when an adult says that it's
childish and it's very sad and it's
destructive and it will harm him and the
rest of society
is it real dark side to this we can we
can make jokes about and we can even
think it's kind of funny if I walk
through the park and I saw some dude in
a fifteen thousand dollar fourteen
thousand dollar border collie suit I'd
probably get a kick out of it probably
take a picture and say oh hey you know
hey Lassie but then the flip side of it
is when
it affects people in a deeper level
right now go to ziprecruiter.com Knowles
if you're hiring you're probably dealing
with economic uncertainty now more than
ever it's important to hire the right
people faster and more efficiently to
keep overall costs down thankfully zip
recruiter is a hiring partner who's
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
them for free at ziprecruiter.com
Knowles ZipRecruiter smart technology
identifies the best matches for your job
lets you invite candidates you really
want to apply to your job before other
businesses can snag them I love how
their pricing is super duper
straightforward you know what you pay
for before you post your job so you can
stick to your budget with no surprises
hire the very best with the help of a
partner that is all about you with
ZipRecruiter four out of five employers
who post on ZipRecruiter get a quality
candidate within day one just go to this
exclusive web address to try
ZipRecruiter for free ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
Justin Trudeau leader of America's top
hat
has just announced that he is separating
from his wife Sophie Gregoire
why do I even mention this story why am
I interested in the marriage of some
foreign leader particularly a foreign
leader that I don't like very much who
has been rumored to be the son of Fidel
Castro but I actually don't think he
really is uh he's only ideologically the
son of Fidel Castro
the reason the story hit me
is because I feel bad for Justin Trudeau
I did not think it was possible to feel
bad for Justin Trudeau this is a guy who
brutally puts down the Ordinary People
of his country shuts them up locks them
in their homes strips them of their
rights attacks the Canadian truckers
promotes suicide promotes
really a form of homicide they call it
assisted suicide or euthanasia maid
medical assistance and dying but it's
just a way to kill the elderly in the
frail and the mentally impaired and the
poor and the homeless he's he's pushing
this around the country such that now a
significant portion of Canadians die
this way by the state helping them to
kill themselves a guy puts pushes
radical abortion laws he's just he's
awful he's he's as bad a leader As It
Gets
and divorce is so terrible
that I still feel bad for him
my interest here is not in Justin
Trudeau it's in divorce divorce is so
bad and we just don't talk about it
enough we focus on the abortion issue
rightly so it's life or death we focus
on some of the radical sexual ideologies
that have permeated the country but we
don't talk very much about a part of
that that is I think
a major
symptom but but also driver of the
sexual Revolution which is divorce it's
just so awful divorce is so awful not
just because it screws up kids
not just because it usually ruins the
lives of the spouses who split not just
because it's in my view metaphysically
and sacramentally impossible because
what God has joined no man can separate
but because the family is the
fundamental political unit so if you
have divorce
then your whole country is going to
split apart at the scenes it's like
cracking the atom the atom is the is the
smallest physical unit and when you when
you crack the atom open things go
kablooey well the same thing's true in a
political order when you crack open the
family
even families that don't function that
well even the families of bad people
like Justin Trudeau it can only hurt it
can only be destructive
and it it is the culmination of a
political process that's been going on
for hundreds of years which is to
separate and compartmentalize things in
our political order so we separate
Church from State we separate politics
from culture we separate economic
considerations from social
considerations we we separate men from
women we separate races and classes and
we just we separate everything
we separate scientific considerations
from philosophical and Theological
considerations we separate law from
morality
all the way down to the point that we
separate husband from wife
and all the way in our in our now in our
sexual ideologies that are that are
becoming prevalent we try to separate
body from Soul it doesn't really work
you know in that one particular ideology
that I'm not allowed to mention on
YouTube I think we know which one I'm
talking about
that
that is so so destructive that I could
even feel bad for Justin Trudeau and so
what's the answer to this well we need
to convince people that marriage really
matters we got to convince people to
stick together and stick it out uh
we also need to make it harder to get
divorced
no fault divorce which was a legal
decision
it was a it was a decision by our Elite
political class
it wasn't driven by the people it wasn't
Grassroots it wasn't bottom-up it was
driven by liberal Elites
no fault divorce has been a complete
disaster for the human race and
certainly for our civilization nothing
good has come from it and
it's not it's not even a a possibility
there's no such thing as a no-fault
divorce if you make a vow to stay with
someone forever and then you break that
that one or both of you breaks that vow
somebody is at fault someone's done
something right it's just not possible
it's just a lie to say there's no fault
divorce
and the effects are so they're so
difficult to even put your finger on I
mean I know I'm a millennial so pretty
much all of my friends have parents who
are divorced and they're not even aware
often of how the divorce has affected
them but I have friends who were
perfectly ordinary perfectly fine had
nice life and good behavior parents get
divorced and then just you you see from
that very moment they start to get a
little wacky and they start to go become
resentful and they start to question all
sorts of aspects of their identity and
their relationship to the community into
religion it just it's so subtle it's
like it's like rayon in a house I don't
know it's just this poison that spreads
through Society you're not even aware of
it
it's even difficult to trace back
to the cause
you cannot solve the political problems
in the country without addressing the
the rupture that has occurred within the
fundamental political unit which is the
family and the rupture is called divorce
very sorry for the Trudeau's boy what a
great clip that was now make sure that
you subscribe to the Michael Knowles
Show YouTube channel see you next time